Hollywood heavyweight Brett Ratner  accused of sexual harassment six women  have accused the producer and director  of sexual harassment or misconduct  according to a Los Angeles Times report  published Wednesday the accusers who  include natasha Henstridge and Olivia  Munn described the alleged encounters  that they say occurred between the 1990s  and early 2000s in graphic detail  Ratner's attorney quote categorically  denied the accusations telling the LA  Times quote I have represented mr.  Ratner for two decades and no woman has  ever made a claim against him for sexual  misconduct or sexual harassment Ratner  has produced directed or financed dozens  of well-known movies and TV shows  including rush hour the revenant and  x-men The Last Stand the 48 year old is  the latest entertainment executive to be  accused of sexual misconduct since  allegations of sexual harassment and  abuse were reported against Hollywood  mogul Harvey Weinstein last month  you